San Francisco has taken a controversial
new step in the use of military-style
tactics by police departments and it
sounds like something out of Science
Fiction City supervisors there gave law
enforcement their approval to use robots
that's right robots capable of using
deadly force and emergencies it comes at
a time of rising crime in the city but
as Jeff porqueas reports critics say the
move could accelerate a troubling Trend
in American policing
San Francisco police are assuring the
public that robots armed with explosives
would be used sparingly we weigh out do
we want to risk lives in the public by
getting ourselves exposed to the suspect
or can we send a robot in to deal with
it the city's Board of Supervisors voted
overwhelmingly in favor of the idea
Monday night it seems like it would do
more harm than good but those against it
raised ethical concerns incited the
impact on people of color and there is
serious potential for misuse and abuse
of this military-grade technology and
zero showing of necessity there are
currently more than 1 000 robots and
unmanned vehicles in use by police
departments primarily by bomb squads
Earth's time a robot was used to deliver
explosives in the U.S was in 2016.
when Dallas Police deployed one against
a man who had gunned down five police
officers the man was killed when
officers detonated the explosive to the
robot carried
in a statement San Francisco police
acknowledged that it does not have a
specific plan in place on when to use
armed robots if we get to a point where
there's uncertainty about who was
responsible for the ultimate death of
the individual causing whatever chaos
they were causing that is where I think
it would be problematic for CBS mornings
Jeff begays Washington
no policy in place so far hope they get
one soon yeah yeah there sure needs
future is now